[Music]
we have a new segment here a new simple
living segment ryan came up with this we
were driving we're out in nashville we
were just talking about
things
and people often come to us and want to
know about a thing should i keep it can
i hold on to it should i let it go so
we're calling this segment a masset or
trash it and the first one we have is
something special by the way you can you
want to hear yours we did one last week
with danny's bobble head
d.k hernandez bobblehead you still have
that you got rid of it nice we yeah we
we decided to trash it now when we say
trashy we don't mean literally trash it
you can sell it donate it it's just a
masseter trash it because it rhymes
right and so trashy means recycling and
do whatever you can to get rid of it if
you have to trash it that's fine
it's better than holding on to a thing
that is getting in
the way so i do want to talk to you
about
well
we have bev from ohio and i've got this
ryan
i'll let you read it okay and then
you'll describe what is in this photo
and by the way if you're watching this
if you're watching the video version
you'll get to see the photo right here
somewhere above me right jordan above my
right arm somewhere
now josh
i really want to do the other segment
that i'm trying to talk you into which
is you are or are not the father we'll
talk about that later
oh all right here we go
hi
this is the first time i have a friend
doing the men's game with me
and we are having a blast sharing our
pics and laughing at what we have
stashed the best thing so far
is my mom's oh my god
jordan right now is the time to put the
picture right here it's oh my god
where's it right here put it right here
my mom's gallstone
that she saved from the 1970s
let's say that
let's put it in a better perspective
here she saved from the 1970s
oh right yeah
that's how old this gallstone is yeah
you don't have to hold it up it's on the
screen would be a better picture on the
screen um
oh my goodness that it's like uh it's
like taking the idea of saving teeth to
a whole new level
like i saved my kidney stones like
let's talk let's talk about the
mentality that goes behind this because
to me it's easier for us to laugh at
this in fact it's even easy for them to
laugh at it right which i that's why i
shared i and by the way we asked bev if
we could talk about this on the podcast
and uh you can send us your ambassador
trash at question just send it on over
to podcast
theminimalists.com
let us know that you are a patreon
subscriber so we can prioritize that now
it doesn't have to be something as
absurd as a
uh what is it a gallbladder stone
stone yeah what is that i mean it must
be a blessing so a having a gallstone
is
something that we want to get rid of
obviously in our body our body wants to
get rid of it and then yet
she held on to it for 50 years and
they're playing the minimalism game so
they're letting go of some things and
one thing they're letting go of is a
gallstone
tk can we talk about the psychology
behind holding on to something like that
you guys ever heard of relics
yeah in in the history of religion
relics is the thing and when i say
relics i don't just mean like oh here's
like a cross or here's a piece of a
garment that's been around for hundreds
of years no i mean like body parts hey
here's a hand here's a hand right yeah
like that's the thing relics are thing
it it makes me think about um
uh retired hall of famer oakland a's
baseball player ricky henderson he
talked about how i think you know
because he grew up poor and when he
signed his first contract he had like a
check a million dollar check and he had
always envisioned having something like
that and he put it in a frame
and had it up in his room for a long
time until like the gm called him and
was like ricky i need you to cash that
so he got like a fake version of the
checkmate and then hung that up and
actually cashed the check but sometimes
we hold on to something
even though he moved from poverty to
wealth
he still didn't catch that check because
he he he wanted to hold on to something
that reminded him of a very important
part of his story which is just evidence
of what we talk about a lot it's it's
never about the thing
it's about the story behind it because
in one moment he had a story that this
is a symbol representing my ability to
transcend my circumstances and then
after his gm called him he he had a
different story this is a thing that's
going to get me in trouble with my boss
once the story around that thing changed
his relationship to it changed you know
did you enjoy this stand patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free